Trump did not fall out of the sky Trump
Trump is the result of decades of
behavior on the part of corporate
America our political system the whole
shebang that gave us Trump you know one
of the important ingredients of getting
Donald Trump as president is first
dumbing down the country to accept
somebody like that as president of the
United States that began a long time ago
with the debasing of our education
system closing libraries making it
difficult for people to go to university
student loans that are 120 thousand
dollars to get a college degree this is
this all is part and parcel of how we
ended up we're worried I mean you blame
a lot of people including yourself
actually yes I am also partly you know
the mainstream media Barack Obama
triangulating Democrats and the
electoral system but there is reality in
there which is quite a lot of your
people if I can put it like that well
when you say my people I assume you mean
people that came from working-class yeah
yeah but but actually the the facts show
that Hillary Clinton won the vote of the
people who earn under thirty thousand
dollars a year so that needs to be kind
of put out there I don't I think that
the people think that while Trump
supporters are all these white
working-class guys that part is true if
you're saying that that I am Trump's
demographic I am I'm a white guy over
the age of 50 I have a high school
education and I'm so that that would
normally that would make me fit in well
with the Trump voter but do you think it
was okay well I understand why they
voted for Trump I understand why a lot
of motive in Trump you have to
understand 8 million
Barack Obama voters voting for Trump
okay so we're not just talking about you
know appealing to racists or for Trump
I'm talking about there are there are
many people who just wanted to throw a
Molotov cocktail into the middle of the
political system and blow it up because
the system had not served the working
people very well over the last few
decades I think that's what happened I
think that there is a sense of
nationalism and a right-wing movement
that is spreading across the world and
we've seen it most recently now in
Brazil this is something that is and
isn't just limited to the United States
I think what happened with brexit and
with Trump's election is that you had
millions of people who felt that the
system had let them down millions of
people who had legitimate grievances
that neither political party was there
for them and and that they had no way to
express themselves other than by voting
for Trump or voting for brexit but
that's that's where I don't I don't
think the majority of the people who
voted for brexit really want to leave
Europe or the European Union I mean just
like the majority people that voted for
Trump I don't think they actually loved
Donald Trump they don't have his values
but when they saw that the elites of
both political parties hated Trump that
made them love Trump you said he wasn't
does that mean you think something's
gonna be really cool
I think that if the election were held
today Trump would definitely be
reelected yes
impossibly in two years time and as he's
sort of suggested you know maybe he
should have even longer a longer time in
the White House Trump is not an anomaly
Trump is very much an American and
carries the values of Americans with him
to sometimes an exaggerated degree but
that whole sense of what's in it for me
and that wanting to separate yourself
from the other or blame the other
is very much what Trump is about and
sadly it's what a lot of Americans are
about and something about us that needs
to change and when we do that we won't
end up with people like Trump in the
White House